hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the chessable Masters division one a
winners section it is Fabiano caruana vs
Hikaru Nakamura and as in the previous
one even though we are in the finals
this is not the end as there will also
be the Grand Final uh which is weird as
you know the word final kind of uh sort
of says that it it it is actually final
uh but they added the word Grant to make
it even more final so I don't know I
feel silly calling it that but that's
what they call it if you guys have any
suggestions on how I should refer to it
in the future uh maybe some you know a
better way also a use uh you know just
uh suggest something in the comments but
getting back to the game really a wild
one let's check it out and they have uh
repeated what we've already seen in the
Magnus versus Wesley match uh that weird
Pawn sacrifice that sort of didn't go uh
well for Wesley so let's check it out we
have E4 by Fabi Pawn to C5 Knight to F3
Knight to C6 and the bishop the B5 are
going foreign
Wesley game and pawn to D for now uh
again absolutely the same Knight
captures on D4 and here uh We've uh had
the Knight captures on D4 Wesley uh
played this move but here Fabi plays
Bishop to C4 and it's still not a new
move there are a couple of um games that
reach this position but Hikaru plays
Bishop to D7 and it is now as of move
six that we have a completely new game
so really really wild stuff uh Knight to
G5 now Fabi goes after the F7 pawn and
Hikaru defense Knight to H6 with Knight
to C3 uh and uh castles by Hikaru Ponte
H3 King to h8 uh so he's uh now able to
execute F5 or F6 if needed and pawn to
A4 so 5V doesn't have to worry about B4
anymore uh we have Pawn to F6 chasing
away the Knight Knight to F3 and now
knight uh goes back to G8 the donut is
normal longer needed here you can really
go to G4 or to F5 so you need to find
some other squares to make the Knight
useful maybe the Knight is going to come
to E7 then maybe to G6 then maybe to F4
who knows so here Knights the D5 same as
in the Magnus Wesley game basically you
will win the D5 Square for your knight
and the black will have to spend some
time getting rid of it from there Knight
D7 C3 challenging the Knight on D4
Knight captures on F3 with check Queen
captures and pawn to B6 now of course
the Knight will be captured at some
point uh Hikaru feels that he still
needs to prepare it with Rook to D1
Bishop to B7 and now Bishop to E3 nicely
continuing development Ponte D6 and now
Queen to G4 and okay
fabiana's position looks very very
active uh Hikaru is up upon but the
bishop on C7 Locked In by his own pawns
is uh well pretty much upon itself so
unless he figures out a way out of this
um yeah he can't really make use of his
extra Pawn so we have rooked the B8
preparing to kick away the queen will
Bishop the C8 with B4
uh very nicely done always a great move
Bishop to C8 and now Queen back to EQ we
have Knight captures on D5 you could
have pretty much captured this Knight at
any point Hikaru chooses to do it now
Bishop captures and queen to E7 uh we
have Queen to C4 uh gaining more control
over this diagonal so you don't allow uh
something like a bishop trade here
although a bishop trait wouldn't be all
that spectacular for Hikaru because his
Bishop would still be stuck on the dark
Square so here we have fonta F5 e
captures an F5 and the bishop cat person
F5 this way hikaru's light Square Bishop
Comes Alive Rook to A2 preparing to
double up on the D file and now Bishop
back the C8 now he wants to trade it
with Bishop to B7 with Rook a to D2
doubling up on the D file and now Pawn
to A6 with Queen to back to E2 and now
Pawn to A5 here asking are you maybe
interested in closing up the queen side
completely and of course you could do
this you could play something like B5
and then he car will figure out how to
a continuous you can't really do all
that much here probably you would move
the bishop double up on on the FL or
maybe even triple up on the f file uh
all depends on what uh what um Fabiano
plays so here Rook the B2 instead Fabi
doesn't want to close the queen side he
will shift or both of his Rooks all the
way to B2 and A1 with Bishop to D7 puts
pressure on the pawn here just Rook the
A1 defending now we have Rook F the C8
uh and uh Queen to D3 uh we have Bishop
to E8 and now uh we have Queen to C4
here you could also consider something
like Bishop to E4 going after the H6
Pawn uh but this is willingly allowing
Hikaru to get his Bishop back into the
game for the price of one Pawn which
isn't really relevant here I mean you've
started the game by sacrificing that one
Pawn uh for a lot of activity so maybe
you know it's not all that great to
traded back let's say Rook to d8 okay
you get your Pawn D5 and already you can
feel that Black's position really comes
out alive Bishop Bishop to F5 you can
even play E4 now the position uh truly
opens up the the dark Square Bishop
becomes a monster let's say queen E5
goes after Queen H2 uh and the black
would be for example completely winning
here so not the greatest way to play
this queen to C4 was played with B5 now
Hikaru finds a way to open up the
position eight captures we have Rook
captures on B5 and now Queen all the way
to G4 Now The Rook can see it is hanging
so you have to do something about that
we have Rook C back to B8 and now Bishop
to C4 chasing the Rogue back and now you
are sorry of course goes back uh Rook to
B7 and now of course uh Bishop to D5 uh
checking I I think maybe even checking
if Hikari is interested in a draw maybe
Rook B5 Bishop C4 Rook B7 Bishop D5 but
nope uh we have Rook to A7 and here of
course you will have to advance your uh
your beep on but not right away because
this is for the moment impossible as The
Rook would hang so here okay back to E2
and now Pawn to A4 Hikaru gets his own
pass pawn and only now Fabi gets his
pass pawn pawn to B5 with Bishop to F7
offering a trade of light score Bishops
Queen to C4 here we have Bishop
characters Queen captors and now Pawn to
A3 attacking The Rook
uh continuing to push the past Pawn
we've rooked the B3 and now Queen to f8
uh there's uh there's always time to
capture an A3 so you're never in a rush
to do that here Fabi plays Spawn to C4
first Ponte A2 and now Rogue back to B2
as the pawn really cannot be defended
with Queen to G8 offering a queen trade
and uh uh Fabi could uh decline the
trade for example with something like
Queen te4 and then just gobble up the
pawn uh and try to put the advantage
there but he already won the first game
of the Rapids the second game ended in
the drawing this is the third game
they're playing so he doesn't want to
risk it too much he trades Queen
captures with King capture sanji8 and
now Rook B captures an A2 fob is up a
pawn and he can be uh he's not up upon
he equalized in material because Hikaru
was up upon this a whole time and now he
just wants to play a nice end game and
okay Rook captures an A2 we have Rook
captures and now Pawn to D5 Hikaru
destroys this Pawn chain and will effort
the trade pond with C captures on D5
Rook captures on B5 and now Rook to A8
with check and this is a very tricky
move by Fabi uh basically
not only finding a way how to continue
this with the material equality but also
how to win a little bit of material the
problem is if you go King F7 Rook A7
wins the bishop there's no defense
against that another thing is if you try
to trade Rooks then just Rook captures
Bishop captures and the bishop captures
on C5 of course Bishops are of the same
color being up upon you are you are
winning the send game so here after Rook
day 8 uh Hikaru had to play Bishop to B8
but now comes Bishop captures on C5 this
is how uh he wins the pawn and now you
could actually just trade for example
Rook captures will capture some beat
with checking F7 Rook to B7 and at some
point okay you will defend this Pawn you
also don't want to lose the G7 Pawn
let's say King F6 will be seven you
defend but uh you know the the king Rook
are too close to the to the Past deepon
of course you're gonna win it at some
point and the white will not be winning
this game however Hikaru played King to
F7 he wanted to keep the material on the
board sort of make it more more
difficult to play as he is the uh well
one could say that he is the better
player with uh very little time on the
clock and they were both I think around
15 seconds on the clock so here we have
Bishop to A3 so you don't have to worry
about this tension anymore and not Pawn
to E4 he pushes that e-pawn we have Pawn
to G4 and now Pawn to H5 with this Pawn
to H5 Hikaru basically uh basically dug
his own grave as now after uh Fabiano
captures G captures on H5 yes he did
mess up his Pawn structure and you will
probably be able to hold this if it's
merely a question of how well do you
play the end game but uh Hikaru played
Bishop to E5 and now of course I'm sure
you guys already see it but just in case
you don't feel free to pause the video
and win the game for Fabi well I'll give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on sporting this
uh mate in one position from the
thumbnail and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show of course it is
Rook the f8 with Checkmate that's it
that's what he uh Hikaru fell for and
Fabi takes the the match without even uh
the needs to go into into some uh sort
of tie breaks so just three games were
needed uh out of the rapid time form
with Fabi won two of them and that was
uh was enough the reason why I said that
this this uh H5 move by Hikaru was
crucial is because now Fabi controls G6
Fabi controls E6 the pawn is on G7 so
you can't go there the bishop here
controls E7 The Rook controls E8 f8 and
G8 so basically there's only one square
you need to cover uh that the black king
can go to and that is the F6 square and
you do that by playing Rook to f8 now
the F6 is covered as well and that's how
you very very quickly uh find Checkmate
you just have to you know visualize
squares that the the the black king
cannot use and and once you figure out
okay this is the only square that the
black king can use then it's not a
problem then you easily find mate so he
car blundered it unfortunately for him
but Fabiano is the winner of the final
of the chest blue Masters division one
uh winners section which means
absolutely nothing as we still have the
Grand Final where he can meet uh pretty
much anyone even even Magnus is still in
the game uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it always careful of
blundering that mate in one but you know
try to visualize as much as possible
because it will also help you find a
very very tricky ideas like these uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank the
revolution reptiles YouTube Eric Holtman
even Sterling Phil casler tags Guru and
Joshua Hadley for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing uh to check up on you
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and yes the
world chairs championship starts in two
days see you soon